who are the most handsome men in the
world past and present
well I gotta name that George Clooney
[ __ ] because why not even Brad Pitt
can't deny his pal George Clooney
and of a good looking guy
I don't know I just have this thing
about me
um yeah so does your ocean 11 co-star
did I rush it felt like everyone was
good I liked it who's answering the big
questions for Vogue who are the most
handsome men in the world past and
present
if I was going to name someone present
well I gotta name that George Clooney
[ __ ] because why not
because usually I'm always taking them
out and he's always taking me out and
this time I'm going to go the other way
just this once George that one's for you
this comes after a long friendship
filled with lots of Jabs we all really
like each other we get along except for
Brad and plenty of pranks
the actual not pulling a prank that was
the problem
it's the fact that he did not pull the
prank he's notorious for pranks he'll
write pranks out for years but once I
heard that he was checking his room
every night then I just stayed home I
did a lot of reading
wow I bet we could find a picture of you
in there too and during Brad's chat he
also Praises ex-fiancee Gwyneth Paltrow
yes I got engaged that's one of the
greatest moments of my life the two went
their separate ways in 1997 after three
years of dating the fast forward 25
years Brad's getting into the beauty
business and his past love was a source
of inspiration saying quote I love what
Gwen has done with goop I think really
what we try to do at goop is just say
hey we're all here we're all human
beings we're trying as Brad tells it he
and Gwen remain friendly exes she is
still a really dear friend and she has
built this Empire she has always had
that in her as a curator and it's been a
lovely creative outlet for her well
Brad's had plenty of creative Outlets
this year too oh I see what you're doing
when the actor's not busy being an
entrepreneur he's making action
blockbusters
and striking a pose on red carpets
around the world but is it what is it in
you that's saying let me have a little
fun that's it man we're just gonna die
so let's like let's have some fun before
we go out
[Music]